want to protect your Google Cloud
environment without spending endless
time researching Point products that
require you to integrate them together
with security Foundation solution you
don't have to
security Foundation is an Enterprise
solution that consists of products and
security capabilities recommended by
Google cloud and designed to help
organizations secure their Google Cloud
environment
essentially what you need to protect
your Google Cloud environment is
packaged up with blueprints and best
practices ready to be implemented which
means you get a trusted partner in
Google Cloud less work and more
confidence that your environment is
protected
to learn more about security Foundation
solution check out the pinned comment
for a longer video